hey guys okay let's talk about the
weekends new album after hours which
came out as scheduled on March 20th and
he has a pretty captive audience since
we're all in self-isolation self
quarantine so it's a very good time for
a musician to be releasing new music
because yeah everyone's gonna listen so
yeah everyone is listening including
LeBron James who listen to it as soon as
it came out last night yes so LeBron is
loving it as are most of the music
critics so let's go through some of the
reviews so variety says the weekends
music has always been about contrast and
here the beauty and the madness are more
smoothly integrated than ever after ours
is one of the most successful musicians
the past decade testing the balance
between innovation and commercially as
much as anyone today
now the Guardian loved it giving it four
out of five stars and said by balancing
the two sides of his musical personality
not to mention add some levity to that
boring bad taste ID after hours feels
like the first weekend album in a while
to offer up a clear singular vision
rather than something frustratingly
abstract now enemy also loved at giving
four to five stars saying it's one of
the shirred albums ever and says it's a
record free tour features and full of
probing self-reflection now the
independent says after hours abandons
the dance ability of its predecessor in
favor of moody introspection this is the
music you listen to when the party's
over
yeah so I will say I'm a big fan of the
weekend I've always loved his music but
I have an interesting history with him
like when he first released his mixtapes
I think he released three over the years
I found I didn't really love the music
that much I could recognize his talent
but I just didn't think he was nailing
it musically that well and even with
kiss slam when that came out I didn't
love that album you could see this guy
had so much potential but musically it
was just so boring it just kind of
stayed all on one level in terms of the
sound even though his vocals were
amazing then of course beauty behind
madness comes along absolutely
incredible album obviously was a very
very pop al
he went in a direction to do some really
radio friendly songs of course through
God I can't feel my face and those kind
of songs incredible album I love star
boy I know people didn't love Star Wars
necessarily because it went such an a
dance R&B direction like his
collaboration with death Punk and that
but I love that album but I do
appreciate it I don't necessarily came
to go full pop but I appreciate that
he's bringing more sounds more beats
into his music then we had his EP guess
that was 2018 my dear melancholy which
really took him back to that mixtape
sound really kind of atmospheric
production and I know people love that
there's some people that absolutely love
that sound from the weekend I don't
personally love that sound it just gets
a little bit OneNote to me and boring I
know I'm a lot of people would disagree
with me on that and I appreciate that so
yeah this is an interesting album with
after-hours because she really tries to
take those two sides of his a musical
background in terms of the more the pop
sound and the atmospheric sound it's the
first time he's really tried to combine
those two
obviously the reviews are loving it a
lot people are loving it I still don't
love it there's definitely several
tracks here that are more of that
atmospheric sound which I appreciate for
a couple tracks but it just after a
while it's like some of these songs just
sound the same to me there's only 14
tracks and it really feels like more
like 20 tracks to me it feels a little
bit long and clearly I know I'm in the
minority I miss already after I cease
from the reviews I'm just not loving
this album so yeah I take a look at some
of this songs here I almost find that
the structure of the album is really an
interesting choice because you really
start out the first half of the album
almost with all that kind of atmospheric
music there's not really any bangers
that all like the singles heartless and
blinding lights don't come in to track 7
and track 9 of course those songs really
explode those are really good pop sound
it's funny I didn't love those songs
when I when he first released them as
singles just because it's kind of
typical that we can pop sound that we
know now I appreciate the songs more now
they've heard this whole album but yeah
like looking at the songs openness we
have like a lone again too late
both those songs
didn't really jump out I mean I
appreciate a loan again as kind of an
intro to the album either that he was
attending a very atmospheric intro but
it doesn't really pop as a song to me
it's not so you get hardest to love it's
a weird beat hardest to love but yeah it
just is kind of a jarring beat that
doesn't really work with each other but
I enjoyed that song the song scared to
live which you performed on SNL a couple
weeks ago I absolutely loved that song
is probably the best song on the album
and there's no child escape from LA yeah
define be yeah they don't really pop to
me in any kind of way then we have
heartless and faith-based once again is
that typical kind of sound and yeah once
you get to the second half of the album
then you get into more I don't want to
say a pop sound but you just get into
more beats into the album like in your
eyes and save your tears and yeah so I
don't want to make it seem like that I
only like it when the weekend does pop
stuff I just like when he does something
interesting in his production and some
of these atmospheric songs they just
there's really nothing to them they're
all just kind of atmospheric background
music that you listen to there's really
nothing to grab onto it reminds me a
little bit of sometimes with Drake's
albums that drinks albums across the
entire stretch of the songs they never
really were completely because there's
some stuff that's just really really
boring so yeah so I do appreciate that
the weekend does this atmospheric stuff
and I do enjoy this mellow R&B sound but
just after a while it gets repetitive
and especially when you have probably
there's five or six songs on this album
that have that sound I know I'm in the
minority in this I know people are
absolutely loving this album I want to
hear what you think what your favorite
tracks are with this I just absolutely
love the weekend I don't love this album
of course this is a I've listened to it
twice so I definitely do listen to it
more yeah I don't love this album but I
want to hear your thoughts